las alarmas antiaéreas sonaron en kiev y
en todo Ucrania Pero esta vez no para
alertar sobre un nuevo ataque ruso sino
para anunciar la sorpresiva visita del
presidente de estadounidense Joe biden
la primera vez que pisa territorio
ucraniano desde el inicio de la guerra
el mandatario reafirmó su compromiso con
este país y anunció una nueva asistencia
militar por 500 millones de dólares
justo hoy es anuncio incluye municiones
de artillería paraimars y obuses más
misiles sistemas blindados y radares de
vigilancia aérea que protegerán al
pueblo ucraniano de los bombardeos
aéreos
es el tiempo que estaremos con usted
señor presidente es el tiempo que sea
necesario
los detalles del nuevo paquete de ayuda
serán especificados el martes pero vayan
adelantó quien pondrá nuevas sanciones a
Rusia con sus tradicionales gafas de
aviador el líder de la Casa Blanca se
paseó por las calles de la capital
ucraniana y junto a selensky visitó la
catedral para rendir homenaje a los
soldados ucranianos caídos selensky
resaltó la importancia simbólica que
implica la presencia de vaiden en la
zona de conflicto además de calificarla
como una visita histórica Estados Unidos
aseguró que informó a Rusia sobre la
presencia de vaiden en Ucrania horas
antes de su llegada podemos y debemos
hacer de este 2023 el año de la Victoria
quiero enfatizar que esta guerra rusa
criminal y no provocada contra Ucrania
toda Europa y el mundo democrático debe
terminar con la limpieza de toda la
Tierra ucraniana de la ocupación rusa y
firmes garantías de seguridad a largo
plazo tanto para nuestro país como para
toda Europa y todo el mundo el
presidente estadounidense tiene previsto
realizar una visita oficial a Polonia
donde se reunirá con líderes de la otan
para analizar la situación y el futuro
de la guerra